so hannah there's an awful lot of
procedure going on um explain to us
exactly what alok sharma who's chairing
this session and the rest of those
delegates are doing here well to start
with there was a sort of procedural
handing or ceremonial handing over to
the the next presidents of the cops so
that's cop 27 and cop 28 that's egypt
and the uae so that happened at the
beginning and now essentially he's going
through the bits of the
agreement that have already been
arranged and committed to the
non-controversial parts basically which
is why you can hear
alok sharma and others reading out these
long agenda item names it's very hard to
follow but it's not particularly
controversial or surprising right now
the stuff that matters the stuff that
will define the success or failure of
this cop is still being negotiated
crucially behind closed doors these
teams of negotiators now working through
the night in a couple of crucial areas
finance is still a real problem in
particular
how much money will go for adaptation
measures to poorer countries there's
still issues with the global carbon
markets discussion and poorer nations
really want there to be a sharing of
funds associated with that that's
obviously quite complicated there is a
big row now brewing around the language
of the fossil fuels
that's at the moment in the cover
agreement text and it says that
countries should all commit to phasing
out fossil fuels subsidies saudi arabia
russia australia and others are pushing
really hard for that to be removed but
the eu and the u.s and the uk are
starting to dig their heels in i think
to start with there was maybe a view
that that fossil fuel language wouldn't
survive but now there's a sort of head
of steam to keep it in which is very
interesting so it's also extraordinary
the idea that you can have an agreement
on reducing emissions without mentioning
fossil fuels and it is unusual isn't it
to even
coal to be named in an agreement at a
car that's right it hasn't been included
before as mad as that sounds and that's
just because it takes such a long time
to get all of this stuff sorted out and
there's so much back and forth between
the big polluters
and the the the more developed economies
who are
much happier to include that language
because they've already made the
commitments they already have the
technology in place they have the
targets set and and they kind of bound
themselves legally within their own
domestic frameworks to do it which is
why this stuff is so complicated
and you know we've got another row in a
separate negotiating room which is
ongoing about getting all the countries
to say yes we're going to come back at
the end of next year
with enhanced targets for reducing our
carbon emissions
so that's four big buckets of problems
negotiators working all the way through
the night to get all this sorted now
well yes and as you say not long to go
until that deadline and and i understand
that you caught up with franz timmermans
a little bit earlier obviously the the
eu's climate envoy essentially yes vice
president of the european commission
that you use climate 10 boy and they
actually have been accused of not doing
enough not raising their voices enough
which of course he pushed back hard on
but he is one of the individuals really
pushing for that fossil fuel language to
stay and i asked him about it
well we will do any everything to
prevent that from happening i believe it
is incredibly important that we at least
have a text that says we will stop
subsidizing fossil fuel we're not even
saying stopping fossil fuels we're
saying subsidizing saudis are pushing
really hard to remove it they're going
to be successful um let's wait and see i
think
many of us are pushing the other
direction
south france tim and evans being you
know really giving a little insight
there that it's all about back and forth
now and who wins the power battle what
next well we're waiting for that near
final cover agreement text to drop into
our inboxes overnight and tomorrow we'll
be pouring through the detail to see how
much progress has been made and who has
won those power battles and whether or
not 1.5 is still alive at the end of it
crucially absolutely okay hannah thanks
so much for explaining that we
appreciate it thank you well we will of
course keep a very close eye on events
uh there in that session uh as it
continues and we'll get you up today but
in the meantime let me just fill you in
on some of the other news from cop and
elsewhere in the climate sphere and
scotland's first minister
has urged world leaders to step up in
the final day of negotiations at cop26
speaking to sky's political editor beth
rigby nicholas sturgeon said a deal is
within reach
there are only perhaps a few hours left
of the negotiations here in glasgow and
leaders really must step up and do
whatever it takes to get the deal that
comes out of the glasgow discussions to
where it needs to be it should be within
reach it is within reach but it requires
political will and determination it is
leadership from the highest level of
governments across the world that is
required and i would call on boris
johnson to come back to glasgow he was
here yesterday i welcome that
in his shoes i don't think i would have
left
british defense firm bae systems is
creating new sustainability
apprenticeships as part of plans to
reduce its carbon footprint the company
hopes that the program will help it to
reach net zero by thirty
and jarvis cocker has teamed up with the
electronic dj
rheton to release what he calls the
world's first sustainable banger
let's stick around aims to encourage
actions to address the climate crisis
the pulp front man has long been an
advocate for climate action with members
of extinction rebellion joining him on
the q awards red carpet in 2019
now the beautiful island of madagascar
of africa's southeastern coast is one of
the countries desperately in need of
more money from developed nations to
help with the impact of climate change
that it's experiencing right now
drought and hunger are forcing people to
take extreme measures just to survive
including destroying the country's
habitats deforestation and illegal
mining are the only option for many who
have no other way to make money but they
in turn are making the climate crisis
worse
well in madagascar an estimated 500 000
people are involved in illegal mining
for many it's the only way that they can
make money as around 75 percent of the
population live below the poverty line
earning less than two dollars a day
sky's special correspondent alex
crawford has this report on how illegal
mining on the shores of lake eye ultra
has devastated the ecosystem
the mountainside is a mass of tents pock
marked with illegal mining shafts and
mounds and mounds of dead grey soil
the forest which was once here is now
long gone
and unlikely ever to return
instead there are men like ali doing
probably the most dangerous job in
madagascar today
they are desperate men turning to
desperate ways to survive
he and his team have dug this tunnel out
by hand the flimsy plastic tube
alongside him is taking the only air
that will keep them alive down here
within seconds the surface and safety as
well as light is left behind
it's jet black without his head torch he
has no protective gear at all and is
inching his way down in his bare feet
it takes two minutes to be lowered down
the tunnel
he and his two other friends are now
more than 70 meters down
crawling in a space just big enough to
take them without a support beam in
sight
they're digging for gems which they hope
will change their lives forever and haul
them out of poverty
trouble is the last time they found
anything of any note was eight months
ago a piece of barrel they sold for two
millionaires about five hundred dollars
split amongst the team of seven
not exactly the fortune they're dreaming
of
above ground lux is in charge of the
most important job his main task is
ensuring airs pumped continuously down
the shaft
but they're working with crude
inadequate materials and alley's not
down there long before the vital airbag
splits is they
now for sure he'll be having trouble
breathing his colleague tells us as the
team tries to patch together the
lifeline with tapes
underground the break in the air supply
is rapidly noticed
but the lack of panic seems to indicate
this is a fairly regular potentially
deadly hazard they often pass out down
here but it doesn't put them off
air restored and they resume digging for
their dreams
what i'm looking for is here you says
i'm always brave with my work his friend
replies
all around them there's equally risky
but continuous activity
around 6 000 people are working here
alone
all this spawns a multi-million dollar
smuggling racket and black market in
madagascar little of which makes its way
into these miners pockets but which
massively contributes to deforestation
affects wildlife and weather patterns as
well as the climate
this is just one illegal encampment in
one part of the country there are an
estimated half a million people who are
taking part in illegal mining if you
look here you can see it goes on for
some distance
that would make it the second biggest
employer in the whole of madagascar and
more and more people are being driven
into it because of poverty and of course
that has a big impact on the habitat
the miners are strikingly positive
despite their lack of success and the
frayed equipment they rely on doesn't
seem to influence their nerves
ally and his crew are unperturbed by the
dangers or the impact on their
homeland's precious environment any laws
preventing this illegal mining are
unenforced how was it ali
they've all spent all their lives doing
this and say they've no alternative
i'm not afraid at all he says i'm used
to this work i make my living out of it
and i'm not afraid
[Applause]
but the forests are coming down at an
unrelenting pace in this one of the most
biodiverse nations on earth
this logger told us he expected to bring
down a hundred trees that day and he's
in a team of ten
the trees are used for firewood for
cooking and selling as well as making
way for illegal mining but every loss of
every tree adds carbon dioxide to the
air affecting the climate and
endangering wildlife and again poverty
is the driver
robert will make ten dollars today
five times more than most of his fellow
citizens the bulk of whom are living
below the poverty line
back at the illegal mining site a gem
buyer is driving a hard bargain
no good
there's a crack in it he
says this group of families have been
working five months to collect this
amount of barrel the gem buyer offers
five thousand nariari
there's nothing good here he says but
famer in the lime green shirt is
disgusted he's got 15 relatives to feed
he's being offered just over a dollar
for months of work
he's not selling today
the gem buyer shows us what he considers
good quality precious barrel gems
he reckons he'll get 25 for all this a
fraction of what they'll fetch when
they're turned into rings or earrings
and at an enormous cost to madagascar's
unique environment
alex crawford sky news in madagascar
to brazil now and the atlantic forest
which stretches for more than 2 000
miles along the country's eastern coast
only a small area of the original forest
remains due to logging urban expansion
and land being used for agriculture but
now a project is aiming to protect
what's left mark austin met the
biologist reforesting the hillsides of
sugarloaf mountain
on rio's famous sugarloaf mountain
they're trying to restore the forest
below to what it used to be
the atlantic forest is a kind of
rainforest like the amazon biologist
roberto guimaraes de souza is overseeing
a project to regrow the area with native
trees
so in the amazon we saw deforestation
here there seems to be regrowth and
reforestation it's a matter of climatic
adaptation for us we need to have our
forests restored so it's not just an
issue of the carbon that is stored here
as other issues as well with the forest
it's a matter of survival for us
because we have many natural disasters
in rio
people from the communities up in the
mountains they usually
lose their houses when it rains
it's happening already for the last few
years we've suffered in the summer with
too much rain and in the winter with
complete lack of rain and lack of water
is amazing but we have lack of water in
the rainforest
we don't have
water we don't have
a clean air without the forest the
forest hold
the the
land in its place
but when you have a president who
doesn't seem to care about this
that must make it very difficult we feel
like this person
doesn't belong
here you know
as if he was sent by someone else
he's working for other people not for us
when it comes to
climate change he doesn't represent the
brazilian people no no definitely not
now
so when you
see
in the amazon what is happening what do
you feel in your heart
man if they know how hard it is to
restore how costly
and to carry to grow up
as a seedling to put it in place to
study to know the right tree to where it
goes have the right species and the time
it takes its ears this forest like it's
200 years old
to get at this stage
no in the amazon i think they they are
just used to see forest and and the
people go there with uh
the people who the forest they go there
with other
economic
reasons to grow cattle they they really
don't care but
we have to restore it if we want to
survive and then we to cost a lot of
money
scientists agree on the need to save
these forests in brazil right now it is
the political will that's missing
now cutting down trees to help tackle
climate change might not sound like an
obvious thing to do but one estate in
scotland is doing just that and it's all
to do with re-wilding and restoring
natural peat bogs to help absorb carbon
dioxide emissions our science
correspondent thomas more reports
the hills above loch ness
and on the bun loiter state they're
cutting down trees for the good of the
planet
these spruce were planted several
decades ago on a peat bog but scientific
analysis has shown the peat is now so
dry and damaged that it's releasing more
greenhouse gases than the trees are
absorbing and on balance the trees have
got to go
it is a bit counterintuitive and but we
have to take down our plantations that
have been planted in the wrong places
like on our peatland bogs and restore
that as a habitat in itself
and we have to
manage our woodlands better so that they
are meeting biodiversity targets
comprehensive measurements of carbon in
the estates trees peat and grassland
have underlined how important nature
could be in mitigating climate change
the bun loita state is just 1200 acres
in size yet it stores the equivalent of
more than 1.2 million tons of carbon
that's two percent of scotland's annual
carbon footprint and it'll be released
if nature degrades
scotland is a man-made wilderness
centuries of sheep grazing sport
shooting and tree felling have shaped
the landscape now estates like bun loit
are trying to rewind the clock and
rewild nature
camera traps reveal the estate's hidden
wildlife restoring nature would be a win
for biodiversity the climate and green
jobs about 60 000 trees are grown in the
nursery each year different sorts of
ones mainly for the very high ground the
nursery at the organization trees for
life gives clues to the scale of their
ambition they want to replant half a
million acres linking estates across the
highlands to the atlantic the highlands
are beautiful but in many ways they're
an ecological desert much of what should
be here isn't here anymore but there are
remnants there are patches of the
original caledonian forest beautiful
peatlands that can be restored and
nurtured and be the sort of source of a
wider landscape change they're coming
around now
but not everyone's convinced angus
mcfadden has 1300 ewes several dozen
cows and he says plenty of wildlife on
his farm he doesn't see the sense in
covering good land with trees
these hills that i'm farming on because
of legislation that's there now couldn't
take trees i'm talking about things like
the depth of peat the steepness of the
banks
we couldn't plant cheese on there so
better a good moodle management scheme
proper grazing regime
to help store the carbon
at bun loyt they're hoping to show
rewilding farming and forestry can
co-exist but it'll take generations and
funding to replant the highlands and use
scotland's landscape to hold back the
climate crisis
thomas more sky news loch ness
well time now to discuss all the climate
issues of the day and the developments
here at cop with john verdick who's
director of the international climate
policy at the nature conservancy so
welcome to you
so we're just 24 hours off the scheduled
end of cop26 so how far away from a deal
are we and what are the key sticking
points that still remain i think we're
close um although close in cop time
means maybe two more days um cops tend
to go over a lot this is quite normal in
this process
the key sticking points there's a big
negotiation going on and what is how do
we make carbon markets work how do we
build up climate finance and then also
what is transparency um
paris the paris agreement is really
important based on transparency so we're
finishing up the rules on how do you
report on your greenhouse gas emissions
okay and and as far as that is concerned
there's been a lot of talk of countries
coming back in just one year i mean
originally under paris they were it was
every five years wasn't it so the idea
that people come back more frequently
and are put under pressure to improve
their targets is is that going to happen
is that is that what is likely to be in
the final text i i don't yeah i mean
there's some discussion of that being in
text i think actually paris said ten
years or five years because it didn't
say so you saw china come with a 10-year
commitment in paris united states come
with five they're both right because
neither was wrong now we've actually
built out that guidance a little bit in
the last years it said it was five
there's talk of one but you know just
like in many of our organizations where
we work if you do a reorganization every
year at some point you have to do the
work on the ground so sometimes doing a
new plan every year doesn't work for
some countries especially if you're
democratic and you change in one year
you might have a new leader that's going
to be more robust and what about the
finance is this all about
enough money for developing countries to
to transition away from fossil fuels or
is there an argument about how the money
spent whether more of that money should
go towards adaptation for example i
think there's two sides of the coin one
side is the remission reductions the
other side of the coin is how do you get
the emission reductions and if you're a
developing country how you get those
emissions reductions is the climate
finance many of the developing countries
also are not large emitters so they're
trying to think of what can they do and
what does climate change mean to them
and it means something different than
what it does to you know the eu
countries to the uk to united states um
but very important to them is figuring
out still how do they feed their
families how do they provide energy
well yes and as far as money is
concerned what needs to be agreed here
is it more money forthcoming or a
different way of it being allocated i
think there's kind of two things one one
is the finish up of the hundred billion
dollars by 2020 pledge and that actually
flatlines um until 2025 until it stops
so i think what we'll see come out of
this negotiation will be a directional
point towards what do we get next year
or the next year but i don't think we're
going to get a number this year but what
we need to do is see if the developed
countries can make up they're about 10
to 20 billion short on that 100 billion
dollar commitment and the one other line
of text that seemed to be controversial
which sounds extraordinary 21 outside
this process is the fact that it
included a a commitment to phasing out
of fossil fuels and reducing subsidies
in fossil fuels apparently it's very
unusual for that even to be mentioned
and there are some countries who rely on
fossil fuels who aren't happy about it
so is that line likely to stay in or not
and does it matter if it comes out i
think i mean it's a signal it's a very
important signal and you have to
remember that the united nations has
purview over governments it doesn't get
to tell all private sector what to do so
in a way those lines sometimes are
saying what do we do here but outside of
the negotiations is a whole other world
what we can push in our own countries
make our own legislatures push i think
that's where we're going to really get
that fossil fuel change
and you were a negotiator in paris i
believe so you understand that feeling
of success at the end of a cob do you
feel that we're going to have that mood
when this does end even if it's not
tomorrow if it's later in the weekend
does it feel like we're heading in that
direction i think so i think it looks
good um
usually at this point of the days you
can kind of watch the negotiators a lot
of them are
nervous they're tired they're being
broken down by the process which is part
of the process the idea make people
start to change what is a red line and
to softly give it into a pink line and
maybe trade it at the end so as i'm
seeing negotiators they're starting to
work together rather than holding hard
red lines i think we've got something
coming and that's something we'll be
keeping 1.5 alive i hope so i think we
we saw in the commitments that were made
in the last week and over the last year
of new ndc's coming in that we've gone
from about a 2.7 degree trajectory down
to about 1.9 that doesn't get us to 1.5
but it's certainly bending the curve in
the right way best guess for the end
time
saturday at 2 p.m saturday 2 p.m i'm
getting a range of guesses thanks very
much indeed john verdick thank you
now don't forget you can listen to a new
climate cast every day from cop26
wherever you normally find your podcasts
and also
you may well already be watching this on
our pop-up channel but if you're not you
can find uninterrupted coverage from cop
26 between 9am and 7pm on channel 525
and skyglass channel 505. that's it from
me
[Music]